you know that feeling when you really
want a particular dish and nothing else
will do that's comfort food malted milk
comforting lunch has to be fished with
peas I've loved it ever since I was a
kid and to make it even more delicious
I've given it a few modern tweaks my
ultimate fish I'm doing the best
crunchiest lightest batter imaginable
with a hint of ginger to go with it
Chile minted mushy peas
[Music]
in order to make sure that the batter
stays nice and crispy and the fish stays
nice and firm the secret is to season
the fish salt and pepper
that will draw out the moisture and
that'll keep the fish will really nice
and firm put it in the fridge for around
ten minutes till the seasoning work its
magic now the batter as always when
making any batter
always sieve the flour or a bit of heat
in the batter so a nice teaspoon of
cayenne pepper season the flour salt and
pepper and then 2 teaspoons of baking
powder
this almost lightens the lobe of the
batter now ginger beer but gives that
batter this sort of unique spicy
individual flavor is delicious for the
fish and a nice tablespoon of oil just
basic vegetable oil gives it a nice
Sheen give that a good mix you really
want to almost like the consistency of
double cream to thin and the bass that
runs off especially when it hits the
fryer too thick and it actually prevents
the fish from getting cooked so you're
gonna get it to that just that sort of
double cream texture let it rest as long
as possible to give you an even textured
batter now the season should have worked
is magic and drawn out the excess
moisture from the fish so it's on to the
next stage fish was gone slightly firm
perfect for fried start by coating the
fish in flour seasoned with pepper
Pat's that nice and dry into your hands
honey excess flour the flour stops the
batter from running off the fish I'm
just gonna check to see them light all's
ready by putting a little touch of
batter into the fryer you see it
bubbling straight to the very top that
tells you that the oil is ready never
really ever fill the pan above halfway
if it all starts to get too hot first
thing you do turn off the gas
second thing add some oil into it to
cool it down hold the fish by the corner
unless you put it in and roll it round
then gently select the fish
the sides of the bowl to get rid of
excess batter now in and lay away and
just gently chop it in twist the pan
that stops it from sticking at the
bottom oil should be gently sort of
bubbling away but notice as we're frying
the fish there's no spitting of any
water from the fish fry the fish for
three to five minutes gently turning
halfway through once the batter is
golden and crisp it's ready they look
stunning so these big crispy pillows of
beautifully textured pot leave the fish
to rest on the kitchen towel to blot
excess oil meanwhile it's quick and easy
chili minted mushy peas now the mushy
peas a little teaspoon of olive oil a
nice knob of butter into the pan shut
off finely chopped that adds a bit of
sweetness to the peas slots into the pan
chew these are delicious
when you eat these and they're slightly
spicy they're even better garlic in the
peas sweat off the chili the garlic on
the schlotz
before the peas join those spices simply
blanch in salted boiling water infused
with their perfect partner
fresh mint stalks on all and then put
your frozen peas in now what's the piece
I've got a nice and soft drain them now
take off the stalks and then add the
peas to the shallows
I love that sound mix all that chilli
and garlic in there a little seasoning
finishing the frozen peas off like this
absolutely delicious onto your board
crush now you cannot beat crushed
delicious please yeah
those peas is incredible top with
chopped mint chili minted mushy peas so
simple and perfect with easy ginger beer
battered fish then I spicy crispy batter
and that just reaffirms the importance
of comfort food you're going to do it do
it properly voila
my spicy twist is proof you can update a
comforting classic and the best way to
eat this is with crispy buttered sauteed
potatoes cooked with garlic rosemary and
thyme
to take this happy food to a whole new
level
[Music]